and daniel tyson able to put it down  offensive rebound corrupted by tatum  he's gonna fire from the corner and he  picks up there's a meeting between these  two storied franchises incredible  no two teams have met more that is tatum  and it tatum just absolutely going to  work on al horford remember that owl  this one to the backcourt off the  deflection three to shoot  tatum kind of let it go for an extra  beat and he banks it in  what do you do he shoots it from 35  feet you falling no gordon hayward  great three sprain of his right ankle is  jason tatum  and because philly just throws it in and  stands there  sets the table for tatum bullseye again  in 23 minutes tonight for harvard tatum  left open splash basketball that that  young man has in him what a loss he's  been for philly as  tatum continues his exploits  at least thinking we could use a guy  like this as he just  elevates snaps bottom of the net